foreign
[Music]
I'm a member of the solutions
engineering team at our studio or if you
prefer I posit Solutions
I help data scientists get their ideas
into production and in the course of
doing that work I see a lot of broken
things and so that's why today I'll be
talking about why I think you should use
rnf
probably uh
so there are two parts to this talk the
first part is going to be about why I
think you should do this and then in the
second part we'll talk about how but
let's start with why and I think the the
reason uh that I'm kind of up here
giving this talk is because I think we
have a standards problem and the way I
would Express that standards problem is
that I don't know if we have a good
answer to the following question which
is what makes a project and our project
um we're probably going to need to
Define some terms in order to sort of
make our way through that so let's start
with project what is a project this is
the definition you get if you Google it
right we've got an individual or a
collaborative Enterprise aimed at a
particular aim I think that's a pretty
helpful definition but sometimes I like
to try to Define things functionally
right a thing is what it does and so
what do projects do
projects ship this is a slightly unusual
way of talking it's kind of a legacy of
you know our history of writing software
to physical media and then mailing it to
your house but but this is kind of the
the Paradigm that we have in mind when
we talk about shipping projects right
we've worked on something I have it I
need to get it to you and I want you to
have a particular experience
yeah
um some of you may be thinking about
like a particular like file extension
that that maybe is like so you're like
it says that kind of thing and there and
I so I'll just say like the I think the
you know the dot R project or the r
Studio project file
um is not going to be sufficient for our
purposes here and part of the reason
that's true is because what's in the
rstudio project file is editor
configuration
um and editor editor configuration is
important to you but when you send data
analysis results data data analysis
results to someone they typically don't
ask you how many spaces you put in a tab
right and so the idea is you don't ship
your editor
I think I think it's important to say
um right I'm making a lot of like
declarative statements here like part of
this is from a history of uh of screwing
things up pretty catastrophically so I
have actually shipped my editor um and
then I ended up debugging my code in our
general counsel's office
um and that that's not where I want any
of you to be right so I think we have to
look for some better ways of doing work
right
well so you know the rstudio project
file is going to be necessary uh if you
use rstudio and I think an important
thing to acknowledge even though this is
our studio conf is that not everyone
does use rstudio right the rstudio
project file is necessary but for the
purpose of helping us understand what a
project is it's not going to be
sufficient
right so we have to look elsewhere for a
definition of what a project is and one
of the things that I found really
inspiring when I was trying to figure
out how to more of a reliably uh deliver
software was a website called
12factor.net The Source I was published
by people who work on the deployment
platform Heroku which helped people
deploy software as a service
applications to the public but a lot of
the lessons that they
um that they published there I think are
are useful even in the data professional
context and one of the things they
really stress is the importance of
environment isolation right so the 12
Factor apps never rely on the implicit
existence of system-wide packages and
there are a couple of things that they
say are important to making this happen
right so you have to declare all your
dependencies and then you have to
isolate them from other things on the
system and you have to make sure that no
implicit dependencies leak in and I want
to dwell on the leak in thing for a
moment because I'm going to give a sort
of stylized example from my past to show
you how this kind of thing can happen
right so let's say
you know or let me say I was working on
a project I did a lot of work on the
2020 census for an advertising agency I
worked on at the time and I delivered
some dashboard and people looked at the
results and it was good and then someone
asked me
um to to do some data analysis on the
census tract level it needed to do
between a one and seven day look back
they're like 80 000 census tracks we
were doing data for uh data analysis for
you know at that point several months
worth of data and so I was like okay I
need to do something this might be a
good case for like the latest DT player
and so I installed DT player you know I
was able to work on the analysis and
everything was fine
uh except I accidentally by installing a
DT player upgraded the version of
d-plier that was being used in my
dashboard because the thing I haven't
highlighted so far is that we have a
dependency on a shared user Library
the answer is uh not in production
um and so I think I'm going to borrow
Julia's excellent metaphor from
yesterday we want to find a way of
working that stops IT from being
possible for us to lock our keys in the
car all right so let's talk about how we
do that right
the first step is going to be to isolate
your dependencies and so in order to do
that you're going to need to install the
RN package and then you're going to
initialize it you have a couple of
options for doing that you can call the
init function there's also a little box
you can check as you're creating a new
project in the rstudio IDE and that will
create this will sort of overwrite your
lib paths right so by default you have a
kind of a user library in a system
library and RM will take that over and
say okay now you have a Project Specific
library and then your system library and
so what that looks like you know if we
go back in time I properly isolate my
libraries I have this user library and
in my dashboard and then the project
Library gets the upgraded versions right
and that means that if I start working
on new projects right say I start doing
experimental things with you know new
packages and tidy models I'm not really
concerned about breaking other things in
my workflow right and the other thing
that's nice to note here right is that
you can adopt this incrementally right
so you don't have to move all of your
projects at once you can see that my
dashboard is still pointing in my user
Library I can go and upgrade that
surgically later on if I want to
and you might be asking yourself you
know okay well you're making me maintain
this isolated Library does that mean I
need to reinstall every package from
scratch each time the answer is no RN
maintains a package cache so once you
install a package it's available to you
to reuse in other projects if they have
the same dependency so that first
installation might take a little bit of
time but subsequent installations will
go much faster
once we've isolated the dependencies on
our system the next thing we need to do
is to discover what they are and write
that down somewhere right and so calling
the RN snapshot function is going to
give us some information about the
versions of packages we use and which
ones we have where we got those packages
from because you know as we've here
heard shared drives you know our studio
package manager of the r Universe all
these are different places where you can
get our packages and so you want to be
able to keep track of where you got them
as well as the version of art you are
using for your project right and so you
can see here this is a package I've
installed from the art Universe
um like and we're so keeping track of
the information about the git commits
right and we're writing all of this down
in the RN block file and I think the RN
Vlog file is the project artifact that
we're looking for
part of the thing that is going to
enable us to do is to collaborate more
effectively and so RMV is itself very
helpful in giving you status messages
about what you need to do next and this
is going to be really helpful for
context where either you're picking up
an old project or you're sharing a
project with a teammate who doesn't have
the same package set on their computer
so you can see in this in this case I've
installed some packages or I'm sorry
I've pulled down a lock file and
packages are in the lock file but
they're not yet on my system and RN is
going to tell me what to do this is a
similar kind of situation where I
started using a package but I haven't
installed it yet calling RM status is
again going to tell me what to do to to
get right right and if I remove a
package from my project then I want to
remove those dependencies as well
because I don't want to ship unnecessary
things to my deployment Target whatever
that is right and so this is going to be
the workflow right we're going to
initialize a project in RN we'll install
the packages we need we snapshot we ship
and then later we can restore that
environment once we have in you know the
project in our end right install
Snapshot ship and restore
I did say probably at the beginning
there are a couple of things where this
may not apply to you one I'll call it a
bad argument and one better one I don't
intend to reuse this code this is too
much this is too much overhead
um
I I think the one of the things about
being a data professional right is that
you are in fact going to have to reuse
the code right someone is going to ask
you hey I got numbers from finance that
don't match yours what's going on can
you ReDiscover that you're just like
you're gonna be in that that cycle of
iteration and so this is a tweet I
pulled from somebody who was talking
about this as I was avoiding working on
this talk and I think it really
perfectly encapsulates that like if you
you just treat things like their
throwaway they're going to come back and
you should just work like your work is
valuable
um if you are purely a package developer
then you are in a little a somewhat
different circumstance because the the
execution Target uh is not necessarily
like getting someone to call your
plumber API it's crayon reverse
dependency checks
um RM does have some some tools that you
can use uh to isolate environments if
you need to do specialized testing and
the the article in that on the RM
documentation is pretty excellent as is
the rest of RN's documentation so in
summary I think we have an opportunity
here it's a coalesce on a project
standard I encourage you all to use RN
and I want to say a special thank you to
Kevin uh without whose work none of this
would be possible
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]